pour en parler nous recevons un nicolas
glières enseignants membres de stylo
rouge l'éducation en colère bonjour
merci d'être avec nous bon d'abord je
voudrais vous faire réagir sur les
propos qu'on vient d'entendre deux
cibles ndiaye la porte parole du
gouvernement qui relaie les propos d'
emmanuel macron qui souhaite évidemment
que le projet de réforme des retraites
se déroule sous les meilleurs auspices
alors oui évidemment c'est son projet il
est prêt à faire appel le faire passer
en force malgré la contestation d'une
majorité de français
les enseignants dont on est les grands
perdants ou le sait ça a été encore
annoncée ray annoncé tout le monde est
au courant
le conseil d'état a retoqué les
propositions de jean michel blanquer r
on a vraiment affaire à un gouvernement
d'amateurs qui passent leur temps à
improviser des choses à bricoler on le
voit actuellement sur les épreuves
anticipées du bac les os 3 c'est qu'ils
sont massivement contesté partout il ya
des déblocages des manifestations et ils
font passer en force quand même c'est
indigne c'est une réforme indigne cette
réforme du lycée la réforme des
retraites elle est indigne
elle est contestée et le gouvernement
continue et sourd à la contestation s'en
moque il est en proie à un soulèvement
alors on voit bien les raisons de la
colère vous les expliquer pourquoi
certains réforme des retraites elle
justement elles portent préjudice aux
enseignants c'est très simple en fait
les enseignants alors du public et du
privé n'avait pas exactement le même
statut régime fonctionnaires régime
général six derniers mois 25 meilleures
années
forcément c'est pas la même chose que
quarante trois années
calculé sur les galères de la vie
accouchement enfin tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer et les enseignants des salaires
qui sont beaucoup trop bas puisque
depuis 40 ans on a perdu 40% de pouvoir
d'achat gel du point d'indicé inflation
non un qui n'a pas été répercuté sur les
salaires
concrètement tout le monde y compris
emmanuel macron dit que nos retraites
vont être minable à cause de ses bas
salaires
donc nous demandent à être augmentée
tout de suite monsieur lancar ce matin
sur france culture expliqué que la loi
de programmation l'éducation nationale
prochaine envisagerait d'augmenter un
jour nous demandons tout de suite 40%
dans les cinq ans pas dans 17 ans parce
que pour l'instant ses 17 ans on sait
très bien que les programmations ne sont
jamais durables ne dure jamais elles
sont arrêtées au bout de quelques années
l'armée en été - les programmations
d'armé ne sont jamais respectées par
exemple alors la fonction publique et a
battu le pavé hier on voit bien que dans
le cadre de ces manifestations
interprofessionnelles chaque profession
à ses propres revendications
est ce que c'est ça ça pose pas un
problème justement parce que finalement
les professions de n'avance pas sur une
ligne même ligne de conduite puisque
chacun a ses propres intérêts en fait
c'était du compliqué aussi pour le
gouvernement on imagine de répondre à
tout le monde
annoncé le contraire le gouvernement dès
le début et des gens qui soutenaient le
gouvernement expliquait que cette
contestation il aimerait qu'elle soit
divisée
c'est logique or on est tous d'accord
sur la réforme des retraites et nous
pénalise tous d'ailleurs le gouvernement
est aux abois
il faut voir quand même que la
répression est féroce on tabasse si on
arrête des lycéens ont fait rentrer des
lycéens des crs dans les établissements
scolaires en armure on met déjà en garde
à vue il ya des intimidations des
menaces contre le droit de grève ce qui
est illégal
par exemple le
le recteur de clermont ou même le
ministre appelle à la répression
nous nous la condamnons nous la
dénonçons nous demanderons à ce que nos
revendications soient entendues et que
cette réforme des retraites qui touche
tout le monde soit n'ont même pas
abrogée mais ne voit pas le jour
nous demanderons à ce qu'on nous écoute
enfin une réaction sur cette initiative
de jean luc mélenchon le chef de file
des insoumis qui demandent son mac a
demandé ce matin emmanuel macron
d'organiser un référendum sur la réforme
des retraites
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais c'est
une très bonne idée pourquoi le
gouvernement a peur pourquoi veut-il
passé par ordonnance de quoi ont-ils
peur ils ont une majorité dictatorial à
l'assemblée nationale grâce au système
uninominal majoritaire à deux tours
alors qu'il représentait une vingtaine
de pourcents des lectorats de quoi
ont-ils peur ils n'ont même pas
confiance en leur propre majorité les
pauvres je les plains
comment est ce que vous allez mobilisés
au niveau des enseignants pour
poursuivre justement le mouvement de
contestation peut-être dans le cadre des
manifestations interprofessionnelles ou
non parce que cette réforme des
retraites a commencé son parcours à au
parlement donc il y aura un vote ans au
mois de février au sein de l'hémicycle
dans ce contexte là comment est ce que
vous allez mener votre combat alors déjà
nous appelons nous nous appelons les
enseignants à être intelligent et à tout
faire pour que la république en marche
perdre les municipales
ce sont nos ennemis clairement il nous
détruisent ils détruisent la fonction
publique
on a un tel chef des années 2000
numériques compatibles mais enfin voilà
à la tête de l'état la contestation elle
est très forte notamment martinique et
en guadeloupe où 90 % des établissements
sont bloqués
d'ailleurs nous déplorons vraiment que
les médias n'en parlent pas je parle pas
des retards mais je gère de manière
générale les médias n'en parlent pas
nous appelons la suite des blocages
contrôler ou trois c'est qu'ils sont
indignes mal préparés qu'ils sont
n'importe quoi nous voulons nous
exigeons un bac national républicain est
plus un bac locale qui donne les mêmes
chances pour tous au contraire ce que
raconte sur michel bancaire et nous
appelons dès maintenant à préparer la
grève du bac
comme l'an dernier puisque nous n'avons
toujours pas été entendu si jean michel
blanquer prétend veut nous entendre
prétend nous écoutent et qu'ils le
fassent et qu'ils agissent enfants
autrement qu'en réprimant cette
répression la condamne avec la plus
grande force et nous allons attaquer
donc si vous n'obtenez pas de
satisfaction s'achemine vers grève du
bac tout à fait merci beaucoup à nicolas
guiet je rappelle que vous êtes
enseignant et membre des stylos rouges
menace est à vous